so we got to graduate people in cyber
security with degrees so we got to wait
for graduation day if kids can never get
back in school so i'm thinking 2041
we'll have this situation handled
senator lindsey graham to join me on
this very topic senator
something brand new in your uh long
career our country was brought to its
knees by our own pipeline
russian hackers but not russian
sponsored hackers
or the one that did it and the president
wants us to go to college
so let me just say this brian the two
responses from the president
biden and his spokesperson are unnerving
they're naive they're weak and they
don't show
an understanding of the problem he
should be saying
we're going to prevent this in the
future i'm going to have a national
strategy to upgrade
cyber upgrade cyber security for
critical infrastructure like financial
services
and energy and oh by the way if you have
electric car
apparently you can't attack a power
plant that was the dumbest thing in the
world if we had all electric cars
the pipeline hack wouldn't matter well
what if they take down the power company
you the power unit you plug your car
into
so they're just disconnected they don't
understand prevention
get every major company in the country
to upgrade their cyber security systems
reward them when they do by saying you
can't be sued if you're attacked if
you're doing the right thing
deterrence let russia know
did russia know about this did the
pakistanis know that bin laden was
living in pakistan
for years yes do the russians know they
have cyber criminals in their backyard
attacking infrastructure all over the
world yes so let's create a
cyber terrorism law that would give the
united states the authority to go
against dark side as if it was a
terrorist organization
so that's called deterrence and
accountability let's start holding
russia accountable for allowing
this behavior to happen in their
backyard with impunity
that's what i would do senator i mean
that's a it's a great analogy because
pakistan didn't tell bin laden to come
they pretended like he wasn't there
but we all knew that they knew he was
there they're mad at us for killing him
just like vladimir putin how dare you
accuse me of allowing this
dark group to exist in my country by the
way the problem with vladimir putin's
track record
he kills people who don't do things that
he likes
these guys seem to be pretty secure they
even have a drop down website they have
a press agency
yeah well it's funny they never attack
russia
all of these uh cyber terrorist
organizations
operating inside russia leave eastern
bloc countries along they never attack
russia
so deterrence is achieved by changing
our laws so that we can put people in
jail
and maybe even use the death penalty for
cyber terrorism
against members of darkseid up the ante
so they'd be less likely to do it
and start a dialogue with russia that
you're allowing this
to happen in your backyard with impunity
we're going to start holding you
accountable
senator i wish we lived in the world
where we can rationalize our way
out of this and be civilized but sadly
we're on the back foot because we expect
people to act with integrity
when are we going to get on the
offensive and i fast forward to
something else you have a passion for
that you do a lot of your free time
where you go visit and find out the
latest and that's what's happening in
israel
they've been absorbing about 1200
rockets have been fired at israel since
monday
they've answered back we're watching on
the outside and iran
had got a big thank you from hamas for
the sophisticated rockets they gave him
is there a link between the weakness
we've shown in vienna in these talks
and what's happening in the persian gulf
to our ships and the rockets that are
hitting israel right now
yeah number one uh they wouldn't be
doing this if trump were president hamas
would not the iranians would be afraid
that trump would hold them accountable
so they're testing biden and and and the
response by the biden administration is
there's moral equivalency here
there is no moral equivalency they have
a dispute about
right-of-ways around a mosque you don't
send 1100 rockets
aimed at civilians indiscriminately to
resolve that dispute so what i'm going
to do
is sit down with some democratic
colleagues and tell israel
i know you're using iron dome rockets to
protect yourself
count us in for resupplying you i'm sure
you have all you need
but i want to go full full all in on
making sure they have all the defensive
rockets they need
to protect themselves and i wish that
president the united states
would take this take a more aggressive
approach
and tell iran that you're the largest
state sponsor of terrorism
all the rockets uh coming out of hamas
for the most part have come from iran
we're not going to sit down and talk to
you about uh sanctions relief
until you stop supplying hamas and
hezbollah or rockets
to destroy the state of israel if he
would do that he would get iran's
attention
senator graham you let off the show with
a bang uh now you can go party
thank you appreciate it hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now